hello I'm dr. Lynn snide and a
University of Liverpool in the UK
welcome to this presentation I want to
thank the conference organizers for
inviting me to talk about the work that
my laboratory focuses on which is
understanding the behavior physiology
and neurobiology of
aquatic animal welfare please do ask
questions during this presentation or if
you'd like me to clarify anything and I
hope to answer all of your questions at
the end of this presentation just to get
to know you better I'd like to ask you
my audience whether you actually use
fish and this can be as experimental
models or as animal Keeler's or in fact
romanians I'm just going to launch a
poll now so if you could say yes or no
do you work with fish and a directly or
indirectly
so we seem to have a 50/50 split so far
with approximately half of you news
equation hath not so hope the people who
don't use fish please find this
presentation interesting and I hope to
update your on the current evidence for
pain perception of fish so as you can
see around fifty percent fifty six
percent sorry of attendings actually do
what the fish so what I hope to do in
this presentation is give you an idea of
the key tenets or criteria that an
animal must fulfill to be considered
capable of pain perception I'm also
going to address the arguments against
fish pain perception and be scientific
evidence for pain and fish
if we accept fish are capable of some
form of pain then we have to have the
means to assess that pain and of course
then minimize it so hope to discuss how
we can do that using non-invasive
measures and how we can provide pain
relief so what are the key tenets well
the first of course is the machinery to
detect potentially painful stimuli and
process that stimuli so an animal must
have noose acceptors the receptors that
preferentially detect noxious
potentially painful stimuli you must
also have pathways from those
nociceptors from the periphery to the
central nervous system the brain you
should also have processing within the
central nervous system that differs from
neutral stimuli non noxious stimuli then
the animal shoots show adverse changes
in behavior and physiology that are not
just simple leaf
exes and these should be reduced by
administering pain relief analgesics and
finally the most difficult and
interesting tener is some form of
consciousness and the animal now
obviously consciousness is a interesting
and in debt involved subject and I don't
have time to go into the background of
consciousness year but I'm going to
focus for the sake of this presentation
on two indicators self recognition and
whether the animal seeks to reduce its
pain such that there must be a negative
affective component that motivates the
animal to pay a cost to accessing pain
relief soon before I begin summarizing
the arguments against pet fish pain
perception I'd like to understand
whether you actually feel that there is
the possibility of fish perceiving pain
when they're damaged so I'm just going
to launch another pool this pool ask the
question do fish perceive sensory pain
so when you injure them is there some
form of pain and you can answer yes
maybe or no
so so far we have the majority saying
yes that is the likelihood of fish
receiving sensory pain we have a portion
he said maybe and a small proportion who
actually say no so I'll just show you
the results from that and I'm going to
take these results down so that can ask
you again at the end of this
presentation so what are the arguments
against fish pain research and well
skeptics and critics of fish pain
suggests that fish must have an
identical human brain to be able to
experience pain so we must have a highly
developed cortex we also suggest that
because fish don't have a human brain
that they are not conscious so any
responses to painful stimuli are simply
newest app to reflexes the fish doesn't
know it's in pain a lot of work has been
published on the acetic acid test and
fish this is a standard pain tests of
mammals and humans where you inject
acetic acid subcutaneously the adverse
changes in behavioral and physiological
responses seen in fish critics suggest
this is just a response to a toxicant
and it's not noxious or painful and
finally one of the arguments that's used
is that fish don't have the same
proportion of C fibers read Delta fibers
that act as loose acceptors as humans or
mammals do and therefore they cannot
proceed pain so I'm going to take each
of those arguments and show you the
scientific evidence for pain perception
of fish so I'm going to address those
directly sue skeptics have suggested
that you must have a highly
violet human-like neocortex to be able
to receive pain and as such only
primates and humans can have pain
perception if you agree with that
definition then you're basically saying
that no other animals mammals birds
reptiles or amphibians experience pain
even though there are a substantial
amount of published experimental data to
the contrary there are other definitions
so one could get down to the semantics
of the definition so for example humans
with a perfectly good intact neocortex
can't feel pain if we had congenital
sensitivity so insensitivity to pain
with anhidrosis super due to mutations
and the NT rk1 gene no fish do actually
possess this gene other scientists have
suggested but it's the connections
between the thalamus and the forebrain
that is incredibly important for pain
perception and indeed fish throughout
those connections so there aren't other
definitions of pain this this idea that
you must have a human brains rather
anthropomorphic really I think we need
to consider that animals have evolved in
a completely different way to humans and
have a different life history in ecology
many people suggest that evolution is
linear so that when fish diverged from
the vertebrate plane that they suddenly
stopped evolving however we knew that
that's not true some people consider
this on a phylogenetic scale such that
fish would have a painful experience but
it would be much more primitive than the
human experience whereas we know they're
examples of animals evolving to develop
different structures that perform the
same function so analogous structures
and a very good example of this is the
avian cortical regions the avian
cortices are totally different in
structure to the human cortices yet we
perform similar functions so to say that
one must
an identical brain region to a human
doesn't really factor in but eeveelution
may have evolved a completely different
structure to perform that function y the
skeptic suggests this that because you
don't have a neocortex it's just a new
si Sept of reflex while they use
evidence from vegetative humans also
called unresponsive wakefulness syndrome
when you stimulate these people with
painful stimuli linked perform reflex
response since at least that's what we
thought until recently Michael it at Al
Michael and colleagues in 2013 which you
couldn't see here they performed a study
on such patients and found that there
was brain activity and the area's
important for pain processing so it is
likely that these vegetative patients
are experiencing pain so this is not
just a reflex response also skeptics are
dest at the fish brain is very
rudimentary that it's a kind of
unsubstantiated and differentiate Bob
but in fact although the fish brain is
much smaller and has fewer neurons fish
are the most diverse vertebrate group
and very successful and they've all suit
we also perform very complicated
behaviors with those small brains this
particular study here by Lincoln bull
Amman shows you that when tracer was
applied to the forebrain that there are
extensive connections throughout the
brain and these connections do project
areas are important and mammalian pain
processing such as the thalamus the
periaqueductal gray the Lucas coronal s
so this does show you that the
connections do exist so studies have
sought to understand whether the fish
brain is active during a potentially
painful event and whether this is just
restricted to hang brain and spinal cord
reflex centers as skeptics have said
so what you can see here is a study by
Peter layman he and his colleague
Rebecca Dunlop performed an experiment
where the recorded neuronal activity
from behaviors in the brain so the Spain
the cerebellum the optic tectum and the
telencephalon organ for brain and what
you can see here is the electrical
activity in goldfish in these different
areas that are mediated by a delta
fibers in yellow here or C fibers in red
and you can see that the activity does
project right up to the forebrain it is
not restricted to spinal cord and hang
brain a my lab we looked at global gene
expression using microarrays
so we looked at the molecular level to
see if the genes were differentially
expressed when common current were
subject to the acetic acid test and what
we did is we compared them with say
LaLanne
treated carpet or noxious stimulus and
we looked at the differential expression
of genes at 1.5 I was 3 hours and 6
hours after the treatment in the
forebrain the midbrain and the hang
brain and what you can see quite clearly
is that most of the gene expression
changes occur in the forebrain at one
point five and three hours at six hours
the fish are starting to recover and
return to normal behavior and when we
looked at those genes we saw many genes
which are known to be involved in pay
perception in mammals so these are
evolutionary conserved to try and
understand this in a bit more depth I
decided to use an approach which is news
in humans and mammals routinely
to look at paint reception and identify
the brain areas that are important so I
used functional magnetic resonance
imaging and anomie van der linden slab
and Antoine and we used common carp and
what we did was we applied either sea
lane to the cat's face or acetic acid as
a painful stimulus and then we took
images
the brain subsequently and what did we
find what you can see from this graph is
that when you apply say lane there is no
significant change in relative global
and signal intensity in the brain so
there's no effect say Lane
however when you apply acid stimulation
you can see that is a dramatic change in
activity and this is actually Deus
dependent here we heard five percent
acetic acid ten percent acetic acid and
twenty percent acetic acid so there is a
concentration dependent response and
this is what we would see in mammalian
studies just to give you an example here
are some of the images that we got this
is a image of 10 percent acetic acid
stimulation what you can see here is the
eyes of the fish here and here and then
we can see the forebrain the midbrain
optic tectum and the hind brain and you
can just see the spinal cord now the
image on the Left shows the increase in
blood oxygenation signal so these areas
light up and this is subtracted from
saline so this is the effects of acid
over and above the effects of saline and
you can see that it is indeed before
brain and the midbrain which is affected
in some areas here towards the hindbrain
the image on the right is the decrease
in blood oxygenation so option could be
used up or diverted away from these
regions and again you can see this is in
mainly in the midbrain so we can see
that activity is occurring in the
forebrain a midbrain are not restricted
to home brain and spinal cord
so think from these studies we've shown
that the brain is active during painful
stimulation that it is different from
innocuous stimulation so on an alleged
physiological molecular and blood oxygen
level the brain is active now what about
this question earth consciousness it's a
very difficult subject and animals
because obviously I've never been a fish
I don't know what fish experience seems
directly we can't measure it all we can
use is experimentation and this
consciousness is news is about me oh
really I think to progress in science
but we need to address it
some scientists like myself and also
Marion stamp Dawkins and her recent book
why animals matter believe that we know
very little about consciousness in
humans we can't pinpoint on a specific
area
recognizing fear and disgust involves
three amygdalin humans so one could say
then one must have an amygdala to be
conscious and fish reptiles amphibians
do have an amygdala however other types
of stimulation for example visual
stimuli require other areas of the brain
for conscious perception for the
awareness or perceiving the stimulus and
what we would suggest is that perception
and awareness go hand-in-hand but
actually when you perceive a stimulus
the consciousness is or the awareness of
that stimulus occurs concurrently and I
think that we need to think right
clearly about what is the function of
pain it motivates us and animals to
avoid damage that could lead to disease
or to mortality so it has to be a really
negative experience it has to have a
negative effect of component for animals
to change their behavior and based on
future decisions on and so for me I
think the perception awareness goes
hand-in-hand if it's not a negative
affective it
spiritually and if it's not deleterious
or detrimental the animals would
continue to injure themselves now other
scientists have ideas that we actually
knew enough about animal consciousness
but we can come out and say that the
absence of in your cortex does not stop
an animal from being conscious of or or
experiencing negative affective states
like pain fear and distress and I'm sure
you are well aware of the Cambridge
declaration on consciousness which did
agree that there was enough evidence for
animals being conscious and that we
didn't need to insist that they had a
neocortex you can actually look at the
video on YouTube and actually see the
declaration yourselves so what what
evidence is there for fish being
conscious well one of the classic
experiments is whether animals recognize
themselves in a mirror and they have a
sense of eye and recognize that the
image is actually them however and fish
motor tests generally feel the fish sees
another image it just thinks that it's a
convict and it Jeremy acts aggressive
towards it Livia and cat seer have led
the other than and cat seer have
produced a review to address this and
then in this review they have said that
there is evolutionary reasons for this
issue and the reasons are that
terrestrial animals actually come to
water bodies to drink and because of
that we often see that the reflection
and not water body silly above all
with a mirror image of themselves soon
be in terms of evolution and life
history they have actually seen
themselves so that's why my tests work
in terrestrial animals however
especially live in an aquatic world
beneath the surface and they will never
come into contact with a mirror image so
they are not sort of predisposed to
recognizing themselves in the mirror and
I think this is a very important point
we need to think about the ecology the
evolution and the life history of the
animal to design tests that that
actually are relevant and not be
answered for more for Barbies on one of
the ways that has this has been done is
by some kin and colleagues who looked at
all Factory recognition and such
letitia's and actually fish live in a by
aquatic soupy type environment and the
chemical communication is incredibly
important so fish when given the choice
between their own odor and a foreign
concept alder spend more time with the
loser so this suggests there is some
evidence for self recognition in fish
the other way to determine whether
there's a negative affective component
associated with with painful stimulation
is to see whether animals will pay a
cost to accessing analgesia that would
suggest that we have a negative internal
experience of pain and let me seek to
reduce that so I designed an experiment
where I tested this video in this
experiment I use zebrafish and the fish
were placed into a choice chamber the
fish were placed in the start box and
allowed 45 minutes to explore one of the
sides of the chamber that liquid enters
through this door was barren brightly
lit no fish don't light barren brightly
lit conditions this was an unfavorable
side the other side had
and plants and also had a shawl of fish
behind a transparent barrier so this
this side was highly favorable the fish
were placed there twice a day and once
we had chosen a specific side for six
consecutive trials we then treated them
either by giving them the acetic acid
test subcutaneously injecting into the
ellipse or saline as a control half of
these were retested in this choice
chamber with analgesic dissolved in the
Baron unfavorable chamber the other half
there was new analgesic present just to
give you an idea what this looks like
here we have like the choice chamber you
can just see there's two doors here and
here there's you can just see some fish
back here the saddle points to fish in
the enriched side and here you can see
in the barren area there's a bright
light but in this case there is a fish
actually in there you can see that with
this are indicated this black out here
and just to show you that the analgesic
stayed within the Buried chamber we
place die in the barren chamber and you
can see that there's very little flush
out from our chamber so we dissolved
lidocaine in the burn chamber for half
of the fish so what did we find what you
can see here is the time spent in either
the unfavorable chamber in red or the
favorite chamber in blue and here we
have saline injected fish the controls
with new energy analgesia Magnus
analgesia or the controls plus analgesia
acid and directed fish - analgesia and
acid injected fish plus analgesia and
you can see that the controls with no
analgesia continued to spend most of the
time in the favored area those with
analgesia again which determine the
favored area
official asset injected painfully
stimulated nice pen mr. time in the
enriched favorite area
even though analgesia acai analgesia is
not present but when I know GZ a was
present you can see that there is a
shift fish are now spending more time
and the unfavorable chamber and I would
suggest that is because they seek to
reduce the pain and are willing to pay a
cost of being in an unfavorable
environment to access that analgesia so
I think that's good evidence that there
is some sort form of negative internal
affective component so we've shown now
that the fish do pay a cost or accessing
analgesia and there is some evidence for
self recognition what's the next
criticism well the response the
behavioral and physiological changes and
responses to the acetic acid paying
tests are just a response to toxic
inlets and they're not noxious or
painful this means that when you give
pink colors there should be no change of
behavior if it's a toxic and related
response but if it's new c-section or
pain there should be painkillers that
will then reduce that response so let's
take a look at some some results on this
and this study I injected rainbow trout
subcutaneously with acetic acid and when
you do this we perform a rubbing
behavior where the rub will be affected
alien to the sides of the tanks and you
can see that in the acid injected fish
there is a high amount of rubbing and it
went but when you administer morphine
painkiller and analgesic you get a
dramatic reduction and that loving
behavior so this isn't a response to
toxic ins and that's also been shown in
goldfish by Natalie Newby and colleagues
we can also look at another behavior and
time to regime feeding
and here we have control sham handled
fisheries were anesthetized but not
injected fish which were injected with
saline fresh administered with morphine
fish injected with acetic acid and fish
injected with acid plus administered
with morphine so you can see that the
control groups museum feeding around
eighty minutes after the treatment
misses when all available physiology
responses have gone back to normal
where's the acid group suspend normal
feeding behavior for around one hundred
and eighty minutes three hours after the
treatment so again morphine is acting is
an analgesic here and this is not a
response to a toxin this is therefore a
response to news reception or pain my
labs test a ranger of analgesics these
are results from rainbow trout what you
can see here is fish injected with sale
a fish injected with acid and then fish
injected with 0.1 Brookland orphan has
point one milligrams per kilogram and
also injected with acid these are fish
with bootprint offering but saline
controls then we have five milligrams
per kilogram of carpal firm the can't
prevent control one milligram of
lidocaine no lidocaine control this line
here represents the impact of the saline
injection and anesthesia and handling at
30 minutes after the treatment and this
line here represents the impact of acid
as you can see there is a decrease in
activity and you when you look along the
acid line you can see it boopin orphan
has new effect at 30 minutes after the
treatment whereas lidocaine is almost
similar to say line treatment so it's
very effective and reducing this impact
on activity
one of the classic responses of trout is
to have an enhanced approach Liberia and
enhance kill beat wait so what you can
see here is the impact
see lane on saline injection on the
throat a particular beat way at 30
minutes after the treatment and
subsequently and then the impact of acid
so you can see there's a greatly
enhanced a particular beat rate this is
much higher than a stress response so
again if we look at this when we test
this range of analgesics we can see
quite clearly that this is the impact of
acid a gamble an orphan has very little
effect and reducing this and mrs. affect
the effect of saline handling
anaesthesia etc and it would seem that
lidocaine is the most effective again so
again painkillers reduce these
behavioral and physiological changes and
so this is not a response to toxicants
and indeed I have never seen these sorts
of behaviors recorded in toxicity tests
and they're not shown by control or sham
treated animals the final argument that
I'd like to address is that fish lack
the same proportion of C fibers and he
devta fibers that mammals have just to
show you that fish do indeed have a
delta and c fibrous this is the
trigeminal nerve of the rainbow trout
and you can see the small myelinated a
delta fibers and tiny on my own a thin
fibrous I was the first to identify him
c sep 2015 22 and more recent work by
Johnson Rockies I've got flix lab and
the Netherlands shows that the tailfin
also has News app twos B's a delta and C
fibers and that has implications for
tail fin clipping so what is the issue
here well I'm sure you know that in
mammals aid doubt terribly to convey
first pain so when you touch something
hot you it instantly feels painful and
you withdraw your hand whereas C fibers
are involved in that late of pain when
there's a lag period and then the bone
starts throbbing
starts really hurting its c5
mediated in birds and amphibians and
mammals see fibres comprise 50% of total
fiber tape and reptiles and fish only
45% are actually see fibers soon much
less and proportion so critics of fish
pain suggest that we can't possibly feel
that later pain because they have less
see fibers
however our electrophysiological studies
have shown that see fibres act like
mammalian sight that a delta fibers act
like mammalian c fibers they have the
same function and again thinking about
the evolution of animals there are going
to be differences between humans and
animals so let me just show you some of
that data by quickly this is the
location of slowly adapting polly moodle
nociceptors these would normally be
innovated by c fibers all but one of
these is a Nadel are a delta fibrous so
only one is a c fiber and this image and
this is the precision on the fish's face
slowly adapting means slow mechanical
suit a slow firing rate for the duration
of any mechanical stimulation and polly
moodle just means responds to more than
two types of stimuli and what we can see
here is a trout a delta no susceptor
responding to noxious heat who damage
that Aliev skin you can see there's
evidence of hyperalgesia we get a more
vigorous response here is a a delta
polly moodle nociceptors showing a
prolonged slowly adapting response to
mechanical stimulation and so basically
the a delta fibers in fish are acting
like c fibers and the
electrophysiological properties are
strikingly similar to booze finder
mammals some more recent work in my lab
has looked at chemically responsiveness
receptors so obviously fish are in a
decreased while they're exposed to any
chemicals that come in and what
we've shown us that these a delta poly
model nociceptors respond to acetic acid
carbon dioxide infuse water and also any
low pH acids or buffers so anything with
a low pH will exciting the receptors and
fish so I think we've addressed all of
the criticisms against fish perceiving
pain and what I'd like to do now is
consider whether the being a pain or
experiencing pain and nociception is
that actually important to the fish
because I can show you that the fish
have the mechanics has been nociceptors
that these are these are similar to
mammals that we process and the right
areas of the brain that the issue
address changes and behavioral
physiology that this is reduced by the
use of a painkiller but isn't this an
important state to be in for fish so
what I'd like to do now is show you a
video and in this video you will see a
rainbow trout feeding on a smooth
species of gammarus and then the two
videos after that the trout are feeding
on a spining gammarus and I'd like you
to notice the responses of the fish
please play began with video
you
you
so you saw that a fish had no trouble
eating the smooth species and the second
video it had a lot of trouble even
spying species in third video the tribe
never attempted to eat cameras again
so this listen important to the fish so
one of the ways that I've tried to do
this is to look at selective attention
strategies there is a theory of
attention just one of the fees that we
have over the pool or limited capacity
to our attention and we can only divert
it so much attention to completing tasks
pain is a very attention dominating
state to be in in humans so if we can
divert attention away from the pain it's
not very important in humans we perform
other tasks very poorly so for example
we're very slow to recall words in a
memory test so I thought I've used that
idea if pains not important I'd be able
to distract the fish for me and I used
two paradigms the first was a fear test
the novel object test which is a
standard for your paradigm and the
second was based upon the idea that
animals tend to avoid being eaten and so
use a product key as very strong
competing stimuli and the normal object
test there were three groups there was a
group which had the novel object a group
which had a familiar objects that we
take the fear out of the experiment a
group which had not object plus morphine
the morphine reduces the pain so we take
pain out of the experiment I assess
behavior before and after the injections
and the fish were injected with seal
owners of control or acetic acid what
did we find or the object was placed 10
centimeters from the fish's head so this
is the amount of time spent moving
towards the object with some five
centimeters what you can see here are
the results for the novel object the
familiar object the novel object plus
morphine for the saline injected
controls and the acid injecting
for the saline injected controls they
shot classic near food we're spending
very little time in close proximity to
the object whereas the acid injecting
fish spend around a third of their time
a very close proximity and do not show
an appropriate fear response
I'd suggest here that pain takes
priority over showing fear responses and
indeed the fish are behaving as if this
object was a familiar object when you
administer morphine you can see that the
fish show an earful bit response we take
the pain away initial and appropriate
for your response and the next
experiment I use the predator key now
one of the things we noticed was that
there is high behavioural variation and
this is linked to the bullseye
behavioral phenotype we get fish which
are incredibly bold very active
risk-taking fish and we also get fish
which are very shy timid center corner
and don't do very much so we decided to
assess that first then we again school
behavior the fish were injected with
saline or acid and then water or alarmed
substance was added to the tank no
alarmed substance is made from damaged
fish skin and it alerts conspecifics to
the presence of a predator and elicits
innate anti predatory behaviors so is a
really reproducible predator key what
did we find
well here we see the change in activity
for the bold saline injected fish and
the shiny fish these are the fish
injected with acid so you can see that
bold controls and shy controls increase
activity and are trying to escape we
don't see an increase in activity in the
shine fish and this change is not
significant so the fish aren't showing
appropriate anti predator behavior
that's also reflected in use of cover
the shaft and seek refuge when we
believe a predator is in the area and
you can see the controls show an
increase in cover use
whereas the bald fish actually show a
decrease and the shine fishing show no
significant change this would be
detrimental in the natural environment
obviously so again in this particular
context I would suggest that pain
dominates and the fish do not show
appropriate anti predator behavior now
fish have now become the second most
popular experimental model and as such
we have not only unethical and immoral
responsibility to minimize pain but also
a legal responsibility and in many
countries
here you can see Fink clipping and
zebrafish this is a routine procedure
for genome screening screening and this
is normally done under anesthetic but
was no pain relief provided fish are
subject to invasive procedures I just
like to quickly pour and see how many of
you actually work on zebrafish as they
become a very popular model so if we
could just ask how many of you work on
fish actually news there were fish as a
model
so we're looking at about half and half
so you can see that around 42% of users
are using zebrafish which is very
interesting so we obviously need a
reliable means of assessing payment fish
and what I'd like you to do is actually
do this yourself by watching some videos
and the first video you're going to see
is a normal fare privations freely
swimming please play video a
you
so it concealer was a freely swimming
come zebrafish normal new interference
self many days what I'd like you to do
now is look at another video pretty F
and assess whether this is a normal
sized fish or not please play site video
D please play video D
you
so what you could see there was a
separate fish which had to tell bank
clip
characteristically we performed tail
rafting when we move the tail very
rapidly to actually move anywhere and we
also see these erratic grouse evict
activity followed by periods of setting
on the bottom so we'll have the next
video video F please
you
so in this case the fish had been given
a pit tag of an abdominal pit tiger
incision is made again you can see that
the fish is spending most of the time in
the bottom part of the tank and this is
often seen in tests of anxiety so if we
could have the next video which is video
G please
you
so in this case the fish had had an
acetic acid test again spent a lot of
time on the bottom doing performing
quite a lot of turns and actually
touching the side of the tank with its
face and we could have the next video
please with your H
you
so in this case there was an acetic acid
injection into the muscle and you
conceives a lot of erratic swelling
followed by a period of actually sitting
on the bottom of the tank so with each
type of noxious or painful stimulation
the fish actually do behave quite
differently and this can make pain
assessment rather problematic certainly
ends up zebrafish as with the trout we
see an increase in a particular beat
rate which you can see here in red
compared to the Saline grip we see a
reduction and be a duration of swimming
which you can see again here compared to
the saline grip but the interesting
thing is that there is species specific
differences so really each type of pain
and each species are going to have to be
some assessed to really develop robust
indicators what you can see in this
table is for example the effects on
swimming we are down here means a
reduction this arrow means there's no
change to common carp soon a decrease in
swimming behavior where zebrafish Doone
conversely no tilapia and pyaar sue
increased swimming activity we can look
at the apparel a beat rate that's a very
valid robust measure in rebel Trenton
zebrafish
you can see it goes up and these two
groups but komak are not affected and it
was not measured in now tilapia or PRC
of course if we accept that there is
some form of pain perception we have to
do something about it to alleviate it
again we have the situation where not
many analgesics have actually been
tested and they had the ones that have
only in a few species so here we of the
analgesics the dose the species tested
and if there's any say
affects and also Vica see if you wanted
me to recommend I'm of Jesus and I've
tested quite a few of these in my lab I
would recommend lidocaine which should
be injected at the site of any tissue
damaging stimulus or morphine which we
usually inject intramuscular in fact all
of these analgesics have been tested by
injection we are now developing the idea
of using immersion analgesia and
obviously and the chamber experiment we
actually use lidocaine we make up a 230
makes per liter solution then we use 8
mils of that solution for every liter of
tank water and that is quite effective
because obviously it's not practical to
actually inject very small species so
I'd like to finish by doing a couple of
things one of those is to pull you again
and find out if you've actually changed
your opinion of fish pain so you're just
going to launch another pool so do you
do fish proceed sound suit pain please
answer yes maybe you're new so right
to report that I've managed to convince
you that there is some likelihood for
pain perception and fishin that this is
important and we do need to be aware of
how to assess and minimize that I'll
just write these down and finally thank
my funding bodies were in the midst of
developing an intelligent monitoring
software system that can accurately
detect where the fish are experiencing
stress or pain and I'd like to thank my
postdocs who who produced the videos and
pictures John Buckley and Kieran pounder
and I'd also like to thank you if you'd
like any further information on our lab
please go and have a look our website
which I've just opened for you now and
just say thank you very much for your
attention and I'll leave you with the
zebrafish face so now I will look at the
questions that have been posed so the
first question comes from George Sanders
at the University of Washington hi
George
he asks have you evaluated the analgesic
properties of ms2 t2 as it relates to
pain response in fish I have used ms
to-to-to for anesthesia during many
procedures we used benzo keen which is
pharmacologically bay similar for some
of the alleged physiology work so we
were all really wash the face so there
was no benzocaine on the face
we still got no see such as responding
there is a recent paper and coid which
is looked at the effects of MST tutu in
surgery and is showing that 150 makes
per liter is the minimum dose required
to thought nociceptive reflexes so hope
that answers your question I think we're
probably using two little concentrations
but then we have to trade it off against
actually making sure that the fish come
drying for anesthesia
so dodge has another question where the
tail fin clip procedures conducted for
these videos done under anesthesia it
soon was buffered and s22 - used we
actually use benzocaine and so we get we
get away with not buffering but when I
have used MST - or obviously would use
butter because it's very siddik and yes
these procedures are always conducted on
and under anesthesia I just think that
that is vital so Anna Valentin from IBM
she has asked in the video of the tail
fin clip how long was the procedure and
under which energy is anesthesia
essentially the procedure probably took
so sorry seconds the actual tails and
clipping the anesthesia takes a few
minutes to make sure the fish has gone
into deep clean and stevia we never do
any of these interventions and less
officials at least but deeply and
sometimes in surgical plane the question
is there was no analgesia provided
absolutely no analgesia we have done
sham controls and sure that the
anesthetic has no effect on behavior so
no this is not junk - the anaesthetic
George Sanders again as if the acetic
acid injection procedures are done
without anesthesia and I guess I've
answered that no don't do any of our
procedures without anesthetic George
Sanders asks when you use lidocaine
dissolve into the water how do you
dispose of that solution after you some
fish
you
before that length of time and then we
just naturally flush out the lidocaine
again we have to assess that you know
there are no adverse effects of that so
what our experiments are quite short
terribly don't last any longer than six
and ones but you know basically we flush
out after six hours is up over question
from Paul Gibbs at galaxina proclaim
have studies compared native red bull
trout as opposed to genetically modified
or farm-raised frame
well rainbow trout are native to the UK
and the ones that I've used have come
from a fish farm so the results that are
presented today are all from fish farm
fish I've never used him at genetically
modified I don't know of any studies
using wild rainbow trout or genetically
modified Alejandro Escobar from the
University of Chile asks do you have a
good guide for assessing payment fish
yes please do look at some of the
references on my slides thanks very much
for your attention my broadcast is no
over it's been a pleasure thank you